[Music]
hello there and merry chrysler
fortnite's annual winterfest starts now
14 free gifts to open once every 24
hours as everything here isn't random i
thought i'd open them all so you can
plan out how you're going to do this
over the next few weeks which boxes have
the best things in them i've time
stamped all the gifts below and i'll be
opening them from left to right do me a
favor if this is useful please click
like and code adam arrow if you do me
the honors i'll shut my face here's
everything in those boxes in fortnite's
winterfest 2021
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
there's
root in the mountains
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you'll also notice there's two boxes we
can't open just yet these will be skins
and damn they are good a frozen peely
for the memers like you and i and a
christmas sweat style for grizzabella
you know for all your sweat friends so
don't forget to log into fortnight over
the next fortnight i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]